[Música]
es tiempo
de sentirnos bien
[Música]
sí
yo no
fin
ah
él
[Música]
sí
yo no
en fin
y yo no
o no
i
no
[Música]
min
amor
[Música]
in the sun
ssangyong
para johan fano
y
me han dicho a mí
[Risas]
el sueño
mal
ah
y una vez
[Música]
ah
hola
cojo
[Música]
a ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
también el tiempo de dulces sueños
[Música]
sí
y sí no
[Música]
e
ah
desde aa2
[Música]
no no
y
y ahora
[Música]
sí
ah
[Música]
chao
parís lo que pasan de
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero también es cierto que a veces el
tiempo juega nuestra contra
[Música]
e
estaré
[Música]
y yo
sí
[Música]
en dar al agua
me canso
y de quién
no vamos
en el caso
uy
aquí
en mí
[Música]
i
no
con él
[Música]
y no sigo
jamás
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero también el tiempo en nuestro tiempo
me gustaría que todos sintiéramos el
tiempo con nuestras manos y nos
acompañará y en esta canción que de
cosecha propia que se llama tango sería
así
[Música]
no sabes pies de mando
una mirada
lacalle un desliz a pasar tango
están mantequilla guarangos
un desliz en la calle
una mirada
[Música]
si bailas conmigo
nada más
y con las olas bailan y tu mente
[Música]
i
hola qué buenos por meros
[Aplausos]
wow
como papá
también es verdad que a veces nos
gustaría volver atrás en el tiempo
[Música]
gray
que nunca
[Música]
guau
por amor
[Música]
y
sí
[Música]
en 226
no
[Música]
y
m
[Música]
chao
y
o
e
[Música]
o
e
[Música]
cantando
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero el tiempo
es una ilusión que hace que las cosas
tengan sentido
y
um
o no
[Música]
o
e
[Música]
stanford que ven web a cruz intense
batió en agua y éste bate
[Música]
uy
qué canción
y van
[Música]
en 2000 en canning ciudad we can see
y después webó
bueno
voy
en qué consistió en el debate
[Música]
james
hoy vive
[Música]
aceite que el tiempo es oro
y bueno aunque no tengamos ese oro
aunque no tengamos un duro siempre
siempre es tiempo de celebrar que
estamos aquí y ahora
y
que yo
duro antiguo que tanto a un cádiz dieron
que hablar
que se encontraba a la gente
en la orillita del mar
[Música]
fue la cosa más grandiosa
que mi vida ha visto yo
o
[Música]
y allí fue medio de corrección y la
pobre mi suegra y eso que estaba a
medias
una villa caravanas
cuatro días seguidos sin mercado
la playa
vargas me están cleto con lo que es la
miseria
algunos cogiendo más de 80 duro pero más
de 4 no vieron ni una
me suena como ya dije estuvo allí una
semana
escarbando por la tarde de noche y por
la mañana perdió la uña y el pelo y
aunque bien poco tenía
fue una pulmonía en el patio de las
barbas y está escarbando desde aquel día
el partido de la barba y está cargando
desde aquel día
[Música]
[Aplausos]